Trascrizione: Michela Scappaticci
Revisore: marshall8 mathers88
Alzi la mano chi si è sentito inadeguato.
Nella propria vita.
Io.
E se ci penso, anche adesso che sono qui a
parlare con voi, sento questo senso
di fragilità, insicurezza.
E’ anche facile ai piedi di una
maestosa montagna, dove la natura ci
ricorda quanto siamo piccoli.
Ma col tempo ho imparato a gestire
questa sensazione e vi dirò come.
Sono Maria Gabriella Canovi e
sono una figlia illegittima.
Sono figlia di un adulterio.
I miei genitori negli anni 60
sono emigrati in Brasile.
E entrambi erano già sposati.
Lavoravano nello stesso edificio.
Mia mamma aveva un negozio di parrucchiera
al primo piano
e mio papà faceva il pittore
al secondo piano.
Si sono perdutamente
innamorati e sono nata io.
Essere una figlia nata fuori dal
matrimonio negli anni 60 non è stato
semplice, anzi, è stato molto complesso.
Io per tutta la vita mi sono
sentita sbagliata.
E ho cercato di coprire questa sensazione
laureandomi tre volte e conseguendo anche
un dottorato di ricerca PhD.
Il titolo più grande che si possa
conseguire è bastato a farmi
sentire meno inadeguata?
No.
Io di mestiere faccio la psicologa e mi
occupo di relazioni, dipendenza affettiva,
rapporti familiari, lavorativi e ho capito
che ci sono molti modi per coprire
la propria inadeguatezza.
C'è chi si ricopre di beni di lusso,
automobili, case, gioielli.
Altri forzano il proprio corpo inseguendo
una bellezza forzata, magari eccellendo
anche nella chirurgia plastica.
Altri ancora, per sentirsi tanto bravi e
buoni, si dedicano a opere di beneficenza
e volontariato.
Altri chiedono aiuto a sostanze o alcol.
Certuni si ammazzano di lavoro.
E tu?
Di cosa ti copri?
Ma da dove vengono questi pensieri?
Su noi stessi che non andiamo
bene così come siamo?
Ci avete mai pensato?
Proviamo a scomporlo questo pensiero
e utilizziamo questa metafora.
Avete presente quando andiamo
in un supermercato?
Prendiamo un prodotto, leggiamo
la composizione?
Magari la tal cosa avrà 7% di proteine,
12% di grassi,
45% di carboidrati.
Quali sono i tuoi ingredienti?
Pensiamoci.
Qualcuno potrà trovare una prevalenza di
preoccupazioni 95% di preoccupazione,
qualcun'altro 87% di senso di colpa e
vergogna, altri ancora ad alte dosi di
gelosia, possibili tracce di tradimento.
Un grande ingombro di imbarazzo.
Ma pensiamo a questi ingredienti
da dove ci vengono?
Prendiamo questo sassolino, ad esempio,
proviene da quella montagna e ne
condivide la composizione.
Cosa pensa di sé , secondo
voi questo assassino?
Quello che questo sassolino pensa
di sé ha a che fare con ciò che
pensa di quella montagna.
Facciamo delle ipotesi.
Questo sassolino è orgoglioso della sua
appartenenza: potrà andare nel mondo e
realizzare la sua agentività.
In altre parole, avrà una buona autostima.
Un'altra possibilità è che questo
sassolino resti dipendente adorante della
sua montagna e non si avventuri
mai nel mondo.
Succede.
Terza ipotesi questo sassolino si vergogna
della propria provenienza,
giudica la sua montagna e
vuole sentirsi migliore.
Cosa succede all'autostima
di questo sassolino?
Vi dirò un segreto tutto
ciò che giudichiamo.
Ci rende uguale alla persona o
la cosa che noi giudichiamo?
Ciò che giudichiamo ci ha vita
e non ci permette di avere
energia per andare nel mondo.
Vi faccio qualche esempio
di miei pazienti.
Giulia ha un bambino di tre anni, Luca
che non riesce a
inserirsi nella scuola dell’infanzia.
Luca non ha regole.
Chiedo a Giulia perché lui può andare
a letto quando vuole mangiare tutto
quello che vuole e sale sui
mobili con le scarpe.
Lei mi dice Mia madre mi imponeva regole
ferree e io voglio essere migliore.
Peccato che commetteva lo stesso
errore della propria madre.
Lo vedete lo specchio?
Lo specchio non è fare la stessa cosa,
ma ottenere lo stesso risultato.
La madre di Giulia non la vedeva.
Giulia non vede suo figlio.
Miriam, un'altra mia paziente
ha 30 chili di sovrappeso e.
Ha sempre storie malsane.
Altamente infelice.
È dipendente da un uomo da cui
non riesce a staccarsi.
Indago nella sua storia familiare e Miriàm
mi dice che quando lei aveva
dodici anni, la madre se n'è andata di
casa per inseguire la sua carriera,
lasciandola sola col padre.
Che lei doveva accudire.
Miriam inizia a mangiare in maniera
compulsiva per riempire quella nostalgia
di madre.
E si ritrova nelle stesse relazioni
dove si sente abbandonata.
Chiedo a Miriam se ha mai detto a sua
madre quanto le sia mancata, qual è la
verità di Miriam.
Cara mamma, mi sei mancata
tutta la vita e ti cerco
nelle relazioni
profondamente abbandoniche.
Miriam finisce per alimentarsi più del
dovuto cercando la madre in quel cibo, ma
lei mi dice No, io non ho bisogno di
mia madre, ho sempre fatto senza.
Si vuole sentire migliore.
Gianluca.
Gianluca è un manager, ha una brillante
carriera, è figlio di contadini e si
vergogna della propria origine.
Il padre, che coltiva la terra tutti gli
anni gli porta in dono delle marmellate
fatte con le sue mani, con i prodotti dei
suoi terreni, marmellate che Gianluca
disprezza e regolarmente butta via
o dà alla signora delle pulizie.
Un giorno Gianluca viene da me disperato.
Il padre è mancato durante la notte.
E lui era in preda al rimorso e mi dice:
Dottoressa, io non ho capito niente.
Mio padre mi amava lo stesso e
io non l’ho mai visto.
Sono stato cieco e inconsapevole.
Che cosa fai oggi per avere un vasetto
ancora di quella marmellata?
Vi voglio raccontare anche di Rebecca.
Rebecca è la mia paziente con una
storia pazzesca di violenza.
Il padre la percuoteva addirittura una
volta la rincorsa piantando una forchetta
nella schiena.
I fratelli violenti.
Alcolismo.
Un insieme di disfunzionalità .
Addirittura la madre è stata lasciata
abbandonata
per strada su una sedia a rotelle.
Rebecca invece ha smesso di voler sentirsi
migliore della propria famiglia.
C'è chi racconta la terapia come
un trasformatore emotivo.
Uno psicologo russo che si chiama
Lev Vygotskij,
parla di zona di sviluppo prossimale,
che sembra una
parola difficilissima.
In realtà è quello che tu riesce, riesce a
fare con l'aiuto di qualcuno che quella
cosa l'ha già fatta.
Attraverso la terapia Rebecca è riuscita
a trasformare la propria storia.
E un giorno mi ha detto Io lascio alla
mia montagna ciò che non è mio.
Prendo solo l'ingrediente che mi può
essere utile e ne aggiungo altri dei miei.
Della mia famiglia.
Nel mio zaino io porto la forza.
Anche io sono stata una figlia
ingrata e irriconoscente.
Avevo un menù , delle lamentele infinito
verso i miei genitori.
Qualche anno fa sono tornato in Brasile a
trovare pezzi della mia storia e amici
che avevo lasciato lì e una sera
mi sono trovata dentro un taxi.
Pioveva, era buio.
Avete presente come può essere anonima
la città nell'ora di punta?
In quel momento mi è venuto un ricordo di
quando io e mia mamma tornavamo a casa
col taxi, che era una festa, un lusso,
perché era costoso.
E in quel momento io ho sentito tutta
la solitudine di mia mamma.
E invece di vedere gli ingredienti che io
giudicavo, ho visto le sue risorse e lei
ce l'aveva messa tutta.
Mi aveva cresciuto in un paese.
Straniero da sola, perché lei e mio
padre poi si erano lasciati.
E aveva avuto un coraggio immenso
che io ho riconosciuto in me.
Da quel momento la mia vita è totalmente
cambiata,
smettendo di giudicare la mia montagna,
io ho avuto una
immensa dose di energia.
Ho scritto due libri a 60 anni.
Perciò io sono qui oggi per portarvi la
mia testimonianza,
che non è volendo
sentirsi migliori della propria montagna.
Poi faremo cose ben più grandi,
ma è l'attitudine che conta.
Che cosa può aiutarci?
Io aiuto le persone a scomporsi, a
ricomporsi
e a quello che io ho capito
è che se noi non siamo
In pace con le nostre origini.
Faticheremo.
So che è molto difficile far pace quando
hai una famiglia maltrattante come quella
di Rebecca o ancora peggio abusante.
Ma lo stesso è possibile percorrere un
percorso di guarigione attraverso il filo
rosso della riconoscenza, se non verso
la tua montagna, verso la vita.
E vorrei concludere con un regalo.
Vi chiedo di fare questo piccolissimo
esercizio con me, di scomporre questo
attimo presente.
E vi chiedo di portare attenzione al
suono che c'è in questo momento.
E a lasciare che le immagini di questo
posto stupendo entrino dentro di noi.
E potremmo anche percepire un profumo.
È un sapore.
E potremmo cogliere il tatto nel nostro
corpo a contatto con la stoffa, con il
pavimento, con la terra.
E poi potremo portare l'attenzione
al respiro.
Scomponendo in questo modo
questo attimo presente.
Ci sentiamo ancora inadeguati.
Certo ci saranno molte altre volte in cui.
Ci sentiremo strani, fragili, sbagliati.
Ma non è coprendolo o volendo sentirci
migliori, ma avendo la padronanza di
questo attimo e questo attimo e questo
attimo, portandoci tutto il bagaglio
della nostra storia e trasformandola
in risorse.
Solo allora saremo in grado
di dire con autenticità:
Ora tocca a me.
Grazie.